I want to switch gears and point out
something that I noticed the other day I
was out at uh Costco and um I've noticed
that there's a lot of
tall men out there with inherent
features that women generally desire
except for they're covered in fat and
they're anxious and they're uncalibrated
and they have man boobs and I just can't
help to think like how many of these
guys if they just lost some weight
properly and calibrated themselves to
what works in society would just be so
much happier and you know better off
because they just have this like Dopey
do do you know sort of like look about
them do you guys see that I mean now
that I've mentioned it you may see it
everywhere now I'm just wondering if
that's something that you've come across
where you're at not everybody's a
leader no I agree there has to be betas
with Alphas you know for you know for
daylight and night time to shine sort of
thing right you made great great point
on cua's show the other day rich and it
was something I noted and you just said
optimize yourself okay no if you're if
you're not born to be 62 and jacked well
optimize yourself if you're 55 you know
as as I said some people are born some
people are born Ferrari some people are
born Toyota Corollas and if you're born
in Toyota Corolla Have Yourself clean
have yourself in shape have yourself
running effici just optimize yourself
yeah so I look over at this guy and you
know he's in the other
uh Q to check out and he must have been
about 6'5 like I'm 6'2 so I'm looking up
at this guy and and he just you know
tall like blond hair blue eyes just fat
with man boobs right and I just couldn't
help to think like dude you would you
would crush it if you just lost some
weight and and learn how to train or
fight or something and it's just like
you know I wonder how many of these guys
are the same ones that are like trying
to hate on us MF you know you see like
the comments of these haters and it's
like they got nothing better to do and
so they make up stories and lies in
their head and it's like I mean like the
ones that you do see they just look like
Goofs and the ones you don't see they're
sock puppet accounts so you never really
know but they're mostly um hiding from
something
anyway yeah I mean the guys that we roll
with the guys that are in this group the
guys that are seven eight figure earners
the guys that are jacked in in shape and
that have great relationships with women
are not on
YouTube acting a fool in the comment
section or the chat section I mean
that's that's kind of the way I look at
it
um so I kind of yeah I I have a
certain belief about people that that
tend to do that in in how they likely
are in real life did you guys see this
um clip with will frell it's disgusting
the caption says will frell is a
homosexual um disg watch this it's like
30 seconds forget about the
entertainment world isn't it isn't it
just
time isn't it just time for women to run
the planet I I mean
I'm I'm s I'm not just trying to Plate
you I
swear but I don't know what else to do
because
we men uh we've been running the show
since what 10,000 BC something like that
and we're not doing so good
so please can you guys just take over
forget about the inter unreal eh dude I
need to relax after 30
I I need to chill out after that because
I'm I'm just just you know what just hit
me as he was saying that um you you
think about ancient um ancient Egypt
ancient Greece Rome uh the enlightenment
the uh
deichi uh France Italy explorers shut
the I'm not going to curse sorry
yeah no he's uh he's I mean he's a comic
so at first I thought it was comedy but
but then when you hear the audience you
know responding to the conversational
pieces and he's clearly not in comic
character when he's speaking you're just
like dude really like this is what you
think of yourself and
men why does so bad well he's old I mean
you know he's gotten older you know we
all look worse as we age dros you'll get
there one day too divisiveness
divisiveness sells okay if you saw
Steven Crowder this week this week his
video he went into a black barber shop
and it was a bunch of dudes he couldn't
believe it you know he just said it's
not as the world isn't as divisive as
the media sells and he went into a black
barber shop and he shot the the [__]
with those guys and it was awesome it
was off the hook like the those guys are
a lot more conservative and a lot more
aligned with um you know your average
white guy then the media will tell
you yeah apparently you know we've done
a terrible job over the last 10,000
years and we want women to take
over D women
over a decade ago women run the world
today trust me we've only Built the
greatest Society in history [__] it's
going humankind and it's going so
terrible it's just this is why you
should never listen to actors or
celebrities there's a reason you should
never listen to these people because
they're they're doing everything for the
audience they're doing everything for
attention live in the real world that
you and I live in yeah and they also
like their their predisposition like
their programming their hardwiring has
been adapted to read lines and act
right so if the Hollywood narrative if
if you know whatever it is that's that's
being fed to them as a function of
culture their agent you know whatever
films they happen to make of course
they're going to start saying [__] like
men suck we want women to take over we
you know we screwed up please you know
save us from our own like you know like
the self-deprecating [__] right like you
saw it with the Chris KO interview as
well right like there's a few times
where he self-deprecating right like I'm
a bit of a meat header I'm a goof you
know like it's like stop it stop it guys
it's about because it's about being
relatable that's the thing it's about
being relatable for them because if
they're the more people they're
relatable to the more people that are
going to buy their stuff go watch their
movies stand specials so that's the
thing they if they they're they're
saying these talking points like Chris
colan like oh yeah I'm goofy I'm just
like a regular guy like dude you've been
on TV for like 20 years I mean your your
family is essential like political
royalty right you're not like everybody
else you are not like us you know you
might think certain things about certain
things but when you're trying to go when
you're trying to have Broad and Mass
Appeal is where your message gets
diluted because you can't appeal to
absolutely
everybody yeah I think I think the
phrase I
heard go ahead was it was it that that
um something not a movie The Social
Network but there's there was something
another movie about the dangers of the
social dilemma was called I was watching
it this week and they had a clip from
every news show but they had Tucker on
there and it was something along the
lines of predatory capitalism he used or
something like that and once once you
realize everyone is selling all the time
you know from the online therapist to
everything else everyone's trying to
convince you that there's a need and a
pain point and you got to hand over your
money for that and you know just once
you unplug from that crap you know
you'll be happier and you know just to
reiterate m m point is like you know was
trying to relate to people so they'll
you know if you look at an ad selling a
product okay there's you know you do a
lot of online gambling back in Europe
and I went I went home and I was
watching a commercial for Sky bet or one
of these things where you can bet on
your soccer team on a Saturday and the
guy's in the shopping aisle and he's
getting beer and he's overweight and
he's bald and these girls come out and
they're all hot and they start dancing
around them and they tell them about you
know where to B I was like who are they
relating to they're relating to you're a
beer swilling soccer fan who's out of
shape and it's you know everyone wants
to be relatable and sell you something I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out